[Music]
all right here we are back once again
yeah doing bullet
yeah this is what 1968 1968
yeah a year before i was born
this movie was [ __ ] badass it was
ahead of its time
yeah very ahead yeah
as soon as as soon as the opening
credits started uh coming along i was
like damn this is 68 the effects were
[ __ ] great
and just the the edits it's had all
these damn
oh the opening credits they had like
titles going by and
there were
there was imagery inside the titles
moving and then there's a background it
was a different background it just
looked really good and it was it was
setting up for like a mafia attack scene
inside the damn credits it was real
stylish
slick real cutting edge look like
something you'd see out of them
a 90s movie like ronin or
like in
what would be another good heat
something like that you know what's
interesting that you bring up heat uh
the michael mann movie yeah is because
the movie heat has a scene in it where a
guy's chasing another guy like through
the through the airport like on the
airport tarmac which is
i don't want to say it's like
cribbed directly from this movie but
it's pretty close
i saw something earlier that had like a
side-by-side comparison and i'm like huh
it's an homage we'll call it that yeah
and then it's like a detective noir
flick
set in
which i had forgotten about because
fourth throw down says so there's a car
chase in this movie but what the hell
else is going on that's the thing this
movie
the car chase is so iconic
that i kind of and honestly i saw this
movie when i was probably a teenager or
maybe in my early 20s and everybody
remembers the car chase but nobody
really remembers like what the movie is
actually about and i think people who
haven't seen it because you hear so much
about the car chase they think the whole
movie is going to be like a big long car
chaser is going to be
or it's going to be like uh you know
super action-packed and it's really not
it's almost like a very very
realistic
neo-noir
cop thriller and honestly i had
forgotten that aspect of it totally it's
very very naturalistic in the sense that
and that was done on purpose
it's very
[Music]
there's actually like not even a lot of
dialogue there's like a i mean there is
but
dialogue's kind of kept to a minimum
some of the scenes are like actually
really long and just have like some
people like not really talking or
they're far away and they're talking but
you can't hear what they're saying
and all of the dialogue is like really
really naturalistic and they said too
that
they uh not only did not build any sets
for this movie at all they just used
whatever was around san francisco
wherever they could shoot
um they also in like some of the scenes
like in the hospital and stuff like that
like pretty much all the extras you see
are like actual doctors and nurses
uh and i think some of the cops are like
actual cops
and not actors so they really wanted
everything as
close to naturalistic and realistic as
possible and that really does come
across in the sense that
this movie is like really immersive you
feel like you're just kind of like
watching
a bunch of cops like going about their
day-to-day job so you don't they don't
seem like actors they don't seem like
you know what i mean same tone as blade
runner
blade runner is a lot like that but
certain edits of it um
kind of sparse
nothing's underscored you have to pay
attention to what the hell's going on
because clues appear inside the movie
and then opinions change
and things are kind of damn vague
or you know
certain things happen and this there's
there's no real resolution to it but it
did mean something it's kind of like uh
it's just real life it's just realistic
um
you're on this damn detective case with
this detective and they're just
suspicious that something's wrong
because shit's not playing out right and
the bad guys know too much so they know
there's some kind of
information leak there's an intelligence
leak happening inside their organization
it's somebody they're working with and
um
suspects appear and then you realize
that it might be this damn senator
that's leaking this
to protect himself because he's involved
with these mafia guys
and um
what's weird about the movie is that
bullet kinda wins in a certain way but
in the big picture the bad guys win you
couldn't they couldn't stop it he did he
did what he could
well and i think that that i mean and
again the theme of it not really
hammered home
but
it is kind of like that's something
that's sort of in the background
particularly i think in this couple of
scenes between
bullet uh frank bullock played by steve
mcqueen and his girlfriend kathy played
by jacqueline bassette
um she's not in it much but they do have
like a couple scenes in it where
she's kind of accusing him of just being
completely
um you know ignored to
you know she says to him at one point
you live in a sewer and it's like it
doesn't even bother you because he's
just very stoic and everything you know
he's very
this is how this you know this is what
we're gonna do and he doesn't seem to
get like emotionally invested or
involved in anything and so they have a
little bit i don't they don't even have
like conflict about it but it's just
something she brings up
and
i think too that maybe that's kind of
where they're coming from like even
though
you know steve mcqueen in this movie you
could say that this was maybe the first
movie that started that whole uh cop
that doesn't play by the rules cliche
um i don't know if there were probably
some before that
but
i liked it because it's very understated
yeah nothing's nothing's underscored
nothing's blown out of proportion you
just have to watch the movie the
character the mcqueen's character
reminds me a lot of deckard
deckard the detective not necessarily
not necessarily deckard the replicant
deckard is a replicant of this of this
of this uh detective well this mcqueen
is just a detective but he's in that
same situation
there's not much he can do he's little
people even though he's a cop i mean he
tries to do the best he can you know and
he does
i mean he he is very invested in this
investigation and getting to the bottom
of it
but
he knows that like you said in the
bigger picture it's not really going to
matter all that much
he can only do things that are physical
all right it does show you that his
girlfriend in a way has a job that's a
lot more high-tech she's like a
hydrodynamic
a hydraulic engineer she knows about
water flows and she can do all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it's kind of beyond him
they let you know that his his
girlfriend even though she's just hot as
[ __ ] is in a way smarter than him
but
this detective is he he's about instinct
and physicality and getting the job done
that way
and who he's up against that's really
not not quite enough
because there's political power and
intrigue and it's beyond it's like it's
not only like political power but it's
also the mob yeah the mob well they're
in with that's what i'm saying elected
officials and they're going to win he
just does what he can
and and being being a man who depends
upon
wit and brawn and skills is limited
it's limited what he could do yeah and
the movie ends just like uh dear the
theatrical cut of blade runner he makes
it back to his girlfriend and it's like
okay we made it at least i got you let's
get [ __ ] out of here kind of deal or
it's over
and it just abruptly ends well yeah he
goes back to his apartment and she's
sleeping in his bed yeah meaning she
didn't leave so she's like okay i'm i'm
in this for that that's the implication
yeah i really think
really think uh blade runner ripped that
ending off
it's that it's it's it's the ending from
bullet
i mean it may be because this movie is
very very very influential and very
influential the same sparse kind of
feeling as
the theatrical cut of blade runner where
it just feels kind of bleak
it is this movie is very sparse and as i
said i had forgotten about that uh you
know it's generally considered it's not
an action thriller really it has action
sequences in it there's a car chase
there's like a chase through a hospital
there's a you know gun fight chase
across like a you know the airport
tarmac there's that but
in a way i like that the action
sequences are kind of like few and far
between because it kind of makes them
more impactful when they do happen
because most of the rest of the time
it's just kind of dry like investigative
work as i said if you are really
involved along on this investigation not
everything is all glamorous in hollywood
and spelled out for you this is like
kind of a difficult
you know investigation that they're
undergoing but uh so fourth throwdown
asks like what's going on so the plot of
this
uh you know steve mcqueen plays frank
bullet
and
he's uh basically what hap he's a
lieutenant vip protection that's what it
is yeah that's what it is what happens
is that a mobster named johnny ross
uh evidently runs away from them from
the mob with like two it's two million
dollars right like it's a [ __ ] ton of
money it's like two million dollars he's
gonna testify but he's gonna testify
against them
uh against the mob and there's the
senator who's played by robert vaughn
who at this point was most famous for
man from uncle he's been like tons of
[ __ ] since then he does a great job in a
movie too yeah he's very he's very uh
oily and
not not physically oily but like you
know uh you know he's oily politician
type he's a senator and he's trying to
score some points with the public
by
having this dude uh you know this
mobster turn against all these other
mobsters so he can look like he's tough
on crime or whatever the [ __ ] uh so what
he does is he hires bullet and two of
his compatriots
to watch this dude over the weekend like
provide protection he puts him in this
kind of like cheap ass motel
hotel and uh he's like okay well you go
in shifts like to watch him
so that's it's just like a babysitting
job
but then not too far into this
uh you know there's some sketchy [ __ ]
going on because johnny ross the mobster
he's in this room and one of the cops is
watching him and he scoots over to the
door and like takes the chain off the
door yeah and then like a couple minutes
later like two dudes bust in and start
shooting up the joint bob assassins so
one of the cops gets shot in the leg and
then johnny ross gets shot in the neck
and he gets taken to the hospital and he
said something before he got shot but
they told me that but that's not what
yeah he said but the man told me or he
told me or something like that they shot
him boom yeah and they went in there
with the pretty cool
pump action [ __ ] shotgun pistol grip
shotgun which appears a couple times in
the movie he takes it apart and puts it
together which i've never seen a
winchester pump do that i got to do the
research i think
i think that might have been a prop gun
i don't think i don't think a winchester
pump comes apart like that
anyway and he put it together quickly
and there's some
i think it was something just made up
for the movie
but it was a good seed yeah these guys
are [ __ ] real
greasy professional [ __ ] assassins
you know um and so then after that
obviously because johnny ross got shot
um
now
uh bullet and his team are in
uh trouble with the senator
who
again was paying them or whatever like
to keep this dude alive like to testify
on monday so now he's pissed and he's
personally blaming uh you know bullet
and his guys for [ __ ] up the mission
and so
bullet has to kind of like negotiate
that whole thing while he's also trying
to get to the bottom of what's actually
going on yeah another thing that
that scene in that part of the movie
i got suspicious what he unlocked the
door
yeah he said so he was expecting
somebody to come yeah and he and he said
but they told me or he told me and boom
they shot and then they shot him and
then they shot the cop in the leg yeah
with the shotgun it [ __ ] him up pretty
bad but they let they let him live
even though he had seen some stuff which
tells me
whoever ordered that hit was a cop
or somebody in with the cops
because why why would they
leg shoot the cop why a leg shot yeah
why'd they leave without
you know giving them a coup de grace
a head shot you know what i mean
they had to have been told that the cops
there were not it wasn't necessary to
kill the cops
they just wanted that
yeah that's the thing there's like
there's all of this stuff going on
underneath
and not all of it is
laid out explicitly
this is a movie that you really really
have to pay attention to
to pretty much everything that's going
on because there's all kind of stuff
because like i said they don't really
spoon feed you anything uh you really
have to follow along and see what's
going on and not everything is just you
know has points and flags like and [ __ ]
like that i started to suspect that
senator immediately he wasn't a cop but
he was basically on the cops sides but
he was defending himself and
i think he wanted to make it look like i
think he was playing both sides i think
he was playing the cops
uh so he could look like hey i'm front
of the cops but then he was also playing
the mob side too he was involved with
the mob yeah okay um
he was trying to look good in front of
the public that he was that he was
trying to bring this witness
out okay and [ __ ] go after the mob
but in reality he was with the mob and
was stopping it
at the same time he's trying to kill
that witness
but he needed plausible deniability and
he was going to try to make himself look
like a hero
that's what i'm pretty sure happened
it's never really
yeah they like i said they never
explicitly lay that out that was just
like the impression that i got that he
was just playing both sides yes like to
just make himself look good yeah the
center was in the mob he didn't want it
to come out because his his business
with the mob would have been exposed
that's that's yeah he was playing both
sides for sure
um and i'm pretty sure that was the
implication and like i said and i'm
pretty sure
even though this isn't explicitly laid
out i'm pretty sure that bullet knew
that was going on
but probably knew like that he couldn't
really do much of anything about it yeah
because the dude was he was a senator
you know and and
basically the agency he was working for
[ __ ] had to obey that senator
and or
kinda although there was conflict within
because the thing about it was that boss
was like yeah this it here yeah i mean
bullets immediate uh supervisor was just
kind of like [ __ ] that guy like not to
his face but he was just kind of like
[ __ ] that guy and he kind of like
was like here i'll give you the rest of
the weekend to investigate this on your
own before i
do it because he got served with like a
writ of habeas corpus by uh by the
senator right so you know because he's
like where's my witness because you know
there's there was this whole thing where
like steve mcqueen
you know after the witness died like he
took him somewhere like he's like can
you put him in the morgue under a john
doe because i still want like some more
time to figure out what the [ __ ] going
on before
before the senator knows that he's dead
yeah you know because i want him to like
not breathing down my snorkel or
whatever so there was that but then you
had the senator and he had this other
cop like that was kind of a higher up
guy played by norman fell matter of fact
who was uh played mr roper on three's
company
before uh don knotts played him it was
you know he was one of the ropers uh so
he was kind of in with the senator so
there was like some conflict there so so
it wasn't
all of the cops across the board weren't
in the senator's pocket or whatever but
they had like a couple of different
factions going on again and this is not
explicitly laid out everything this
movie is like very subtle and very
subdued which like i said i was
surprised because i had forgotten about
that and just because so many people
talk about the car chase and the car
chase happens about an hour in
that's when the two guys that shot the
witness at the beginning like start
chasing uh you know steve mcqueen around
in their uh dodge charger
and uh and so he's like trying to escape
them so it's like this really it's i
think it's like a 10 minute chase
san francisco the way it was filmed uh
was pretty good it involved some
motorcycles a bunch of other cars and
and you can see right where uh
right where mad max came from it's very
mad something out of mad max it was a
real wave was filmed it was realistic
there were car there had to have been
cameras on car hoods and
cameras sticking out of car windows and
people filming from inside the car
so it's because it makes you really feel
like you're in there and like i said
it's not glamorous it's not like a
hollywood
like a normal hollywood like like
something you would see nowadays like in
like a tom cruise mission impossible
movie or something like which are cool
but and like everything but
this one is a lot more realistic and
kind of made you feel like you were kind
of in it your cars are getting all
crunched up and you can see that that's
steve mcqueen driving
he drives for all the close-up shots uh
his um his uh the stunt court the stunt
guys like drove for like the far shots
including the same guy that did the
motorcycle jump yeah uh you know that
that guy bud eakins i think his name is
mcqueen was kind of like tom cruise of
his day you know he really could drive
you know chris cruz couldn't drive yeah
all the if you can see steve mcqueen
driving he's actually driving mcqueen
was a good club racer you know he did
motorcycle and car racing and put a
bunch of different events and was good
you know he was he was good
and had a bunch of custom cars made all
the [ __ ] california hot rod shops and
knew him and if if a badass car would
come out he would have like he'd buy
that badass car stock and then send it
to those custom hot rod shops and then
put the best [ __ ] on it you could get
you know porsches
corvettes
[ __ ]
everything mustangs the car in this
[ __ ]
movie is pretty uh
famous
ever a lot of you mustang guys try to
copy it called a bullet mustang or the
bullet edition mustang it's just a green
mustang fastback and i guess it was a 68
or 67 i don't know exactly they well and
honestly they only use two for this
movie because i was wondering about that
because they do it does get kind of
trash but um they only used two of them
and they had like the stunt coordinators
like they souped the [ __ ] out of that
well and honestly too because they also
had two dodge chargers like the mob's
car
and uh they said actually just naturally
right out the box the dodge charger was
much faster yeah than the mustangs so
they had to keep they had to soup up the
mustang and then they had to shoot it so
that the charger
would stop like and i'm assuming
overrunning it i'm assuming the
soundtrack recordings for for the for
the bullet mustang or what was in the
bullet it's it's definitely a v8 and it
sounds like it's got some real hot cams
in it high compression engine i mean
[ __ ]
it's singing
that's another thing that i think one
made the car chase so much more exciting
and visceral but also was really um and
i saw a video that was pointing out that
like even you know like the uh you know
the the fights in star wars and stuff
where you can hear the whoa like the
ships and everything they said a lot of
that might have been from this movie
because this was kind of the first one
to do because normally you'd have a car
chase and you'd have doom doom doo doo
doo doo like some music or something
this you don't have there's no music
it's just like the sounds of the engines
yeah and it makes it like a lot more
immersive i think they're going downhill
on these [ __ ] san francisco [ __ ]
yeah down there [ __ ] crash
crashing them damn cars up the mustang's
landing on all four wheels though he's
landing it good
[ __ ] you but he's he's sticking the
landings pretty good uh the [ __ ] the
uh the charger is getting banged up
[ __ ] hubcaps go flying off of it uh
they're hitting some pretty hot turns
and the [ __ ] hubcap all the dead
hubcaps on a charger [ __ ] comes
flying off and they couldn't have
planned that so a lot of that is just
[ __ ] um really hard driving now it's
funny because this is 68 and those cars
were pretty hot for the time they were
street cars too
you know
it was something that a cop could afford
so had so you know what i mean it was
realistic
um
they're [ __ ] driving those cars as
fast as they would go in those
conditions yeah um but really not fast
cars by today's standards just
kind of good looking and mean looking
from what i could determine because we
thought at some points were like did
they speed the film up some of it was i
don't think it was though because um at
least not that i could determine they
said they actually did drive the cars
generally between 65 and 85 although at
some points it did go up to 110 yeah
which that's about it for those goals so
they were driving to the you know the
fastest like to the limit of their speed
i guess because like i said we couldn't
really tell i was like i don't know if
they sped the film because i know they
did that sometimes like in cheaper
movies yeah uh to make it look like the
cars were going faster but i don't think
they did in this one the problem with
the cars of that era is that
first of all they were heavy they were
all steel construction
they didn't make that much horsepower
they made pretty good torque they didn't
have very good brakes the tires were
[ __ ]
and the contact patches wasn't much in
other words the tires are not very fat
um so you can't get a lot of power to
the ground and you can't get a lot of
brake to the ground so they slid around
quite a bit and they had shitty
suspensions they pogo i would think
brakes and suspension were like the
biggest limitation of cars that era
um and they were [ __ ] catching air on
them but they tended to pogo and roll in
turns
unless they were heavily modified with
the best stuff
which i kind of by the way that bullet
mustang was landing on all four
tires
it must have had a pretty suped up
suspension a good suspension on it yeah
it was all it was all kitted out it
wasn't it wasn't stock yeah the charger
was closer to stock that's why i was
getting beat up so bad but um it was
still modified too but the mustangs were
uh extensively modest
it was tracking pretty well and landing
pretty well it stock
stock mustang wouldn't have from that
era would have pogoed like crazy yeah
and rolled real bad
and not landed on all four uh tires it
would have landed nose first
usually so it must it must have been
carrying weight in the rear to get it to
land properly
either weight had been reduced from the
front something because they they didn't
have very good weight distribution
yeah i mean they knew what they were
doing back then
um grampar said mcqueen reportedly had
one of the biggest dongs in hollywood
one girlfriend said it was like two beer
cans welded together mcqueen was no joke
goddamn yeah
queen was no joke i mean everybody
respected him he was a tough dude and uh
i mean he's cool as [ __ ] he's i mean
even still nowadays he's still
considered like an icon of cool
everybody liked him uh he'd show up to
hollywood parties and [ __ ] you know
what i mean and was cool with everybody
and he'd show up with [ __ ] hotties
and this [ __ ] badass [ __ ] cars and
i think he pretty much only dated like
top-notch stars actresses i don't think
he dated
women that weren't famous but um you
know
maybe he did but he was known for start
dating stars whoever the hottest star
was at that time
but he would show up to parties and
dazzle people and [ __ ] was just cool
and sit around and he he really wasn't
evidently he wasn't the kind of guy that
was like a theater type guy he was more
like a
racing type guy and
fighting and you know reading [ __ ]
history books he was that kind of guy
more than he was like a theater dude
um
but he he hung out with people the
theater you know actually i think
that
once upon a time in hollywood that knew
quentin tarantino film
in that party has somebody playing steve
mcqueen's yeah that's right i think yeah
i think i think
evidently pretty much everyone was
pretty much portrayed as kind of how the
how they were known including
including bruce lee
that's kind of what he was like too even
though some people thought that was
disrespectful bruce lee i don't think it
was
bruce was a young guy they did all kinds
of [ __ ] and bruce talked a lot of [ __ ]
he you know yeah he was fast yeah he was
he was a good martial artist but anyway
anything he got his ass kicked today in
mixed martial arts arts
[ __ ] mma bruce lee to get his ass
kicked out of frame
could he train gain some weight and do
good in mma yeah he could he was he was
the kind of guy that did trade he wasn't
a fake he was just a man of his time
they all were
yeah the thing i was gonna say about
steve mcqueen too i've you know i
haven't seen all of his movies uh you
know but
honestly in i think it's good in this
one because you can actually see that
like the man can act you know what i
mean you really got a sense because he
doesn't have a lot of dialogue in this
you know what i mean he's very stoic his
character reality actor yeah but you can
like you can still tell what's going on
in his head
just by kind of like the look on his
face
and it's not showy
uh it's not theatrical he's just very
very natural yeah in this movie and i
really really like that role zach says
um i really love the cinematography in
this movie the lighting and angles are
super modern seeming for the 60s yeah i
noticed that as well love this era of
filmmaking i mean this movie
so
so influential and it's like honestly
it's probably movies you wouldn't even
think would be influenced by this were
influenced by this
mcqueen always kind of reminded me of
like kind of like the natural
the naturalistic element of say like
harrison ford now harrison ford kind of
seems like he's just being himself yeah
he reminded me that that
mixed with kind of like
the some of the intensity of tom cruise
but without the kind of tom cruise kind
of has that his cockiness yeah without
that cocky douchery yeah like that it's
kind of like
imagine if harrison ford was more like
tom cruise that's way that's the way
mcqueen kind of
feels to me watching him on on the
screen yeah i really think
harrison ford was channeling bullet when
he did
uh blade runner
i mean he very well may have been
because like i said a lot of this movie
is like really really it was really
influential because not only was it a
massive critical success it was also a
big audience success also this made like
a lot of money like when it came out and
the editing won an academy award yeah
it's a good movie uh that too i mean
probably mostly for the car chasing
which is edited like
like that but i mean the whole thing but
like i said i really liked how
subdued this movie was it almost kind of
reminded me of like maybe like a david
fincher movie but not even as showy as
that it was just a very matter-of-fact
down to earth
immersive
it's very realistic
yeah but like not
not like overtly
yeah it just is it's just very very
realistic and i think it helped that
they used like a lot of like i said real
doctors real nurses real cops
um they used all real locations they
didn't build anything they didn't do set
dressing to any great degree or anything
like that they just used what was there
there's this good there was this good
scene where mcqueen is talking to the
doctor who's taking care of his buddy
who got a leg shot and that doctor's a
young black guy and [ __ ] dudes
evidently he's right out of medical
school and he's doing a good job [ __ ]
on him and mcqueen's kind of chilled out
to the fact that this dude's doing a
good job
senator comes in and pulls that [ __ ]
dude off under the excuse well he's too
young i don't want him on this he's too
inexperienced
yeah two black
but he wanted to get he didn't say that
but that was that was the unspoken right
right mcqueen mcqueen's looking at the
[ __ ] black dude and like just look at
him like men's [ __ ] a dick yeah
nobody says anything but you know
exactly what's passing between you
[Laughter]
he was doing the same kind of thing with
mcqueen right before that had happened
but remember that he was [ __ ]
basically
just trying to piss off steve mcqueen
blame him for [ __ ] [ __ ] that he
didn't have any control over he wasn't
there when the [ __ ] attack happened
yeah it wasn't his shift right it was it
was one of his partners he's blaming him
anyway and that standard kept [ __ ]
doing things like it's just
sketchy [ __ ] okay
threatening your career
by talking bad about you in the into the
in the public eye he says you know i
could destroy somebody just by saying
bad [ __ ] because bullet was kind of well
known
you know i forgot to mention that too
he's kind of like a golden boy and then
he turned around and basically said you
know a guy like you could go far you
know what i mean if you you know if you
do what i care about so he's [ __ ]
doing this and he was doing it to to
bullet and his boss and [ __ ]
everybody and it's obvious to me that
the dude is trying to manipulate the
system to get that witness killed but he
doesn't want anybody to know that right
i was pretty sure
i mean he was just a mom i kind of think
he was trying to play both sides for the
public he was trying to be this big
crime fighter but he was really trying
to kill that witness yeah yeah that's
what i think was going on well i think
he wanted to kill the witness who could
blame it on the cops yeah i want to
blame it on the cops but he wanted to
kill the witness because the witness was
because see that would have been win-win
yeah that would that witness was going
to say something that would have
implicated that senator yes
he just wanted to be well i would have
had you know i would have had this
mobster i had it all lined up and the
cops [ __ ] it up you know what i mean i
kind of feel like that was his and he
wanted the he wanted the young black
doctor off that case and get his own
doctor on there to to decrease that cops
chance of survival because that cop saw
the [ __ ] assassins
yeah i think he wanted to get his own
man in there
yeah i kind of wasn't just a race thing
he wanted people to think it was a race
thing it's not what it was
that that doctor was helping him he
wanted a doctor that would go in there
and kill him that's what i think it was
i kind of thought that too yeah and like
i said a lot of this is
sublimated it never is
never
yeah
they never explain it necessarily it's
just kind of like but i'm kind of
thinking if you pay attention to all the
little clues and stuff in there you can
pretty much
suss out what's going on
well [ __ ] mcqueen tell the senator
but you know basically you're just
you're a suspect
yeah and that that was [ __ ] really
when the [ __ ]
started going down
mcqueen says i think you had something
to do with this
yeah yeah i think so too yeah because i
even said when i was watching the movie
i agree with you steve mcqueen yeah
grampur's hammer said whenever hollywood
films a movie in michigan they always
hire real cops to play movie cops
because they have a swagger that extras
can't replicate i submitted a mug shot a
couple of times but they didn't dig the
cut of my gym evidently
best detroit cop movie was [ __ ]
beverly hills cop well i like that one
remember eddie murphy was in that and
then his boss was the his boss in the
movie was the real police chief of
detroit got that guy's name he was
famous back in when we were kids
i forgot that cop's name but he did
great in that movie with daddy murphy uh
fun fact speaking of real cops is that
steve mcqueen based his character frank
bullet on a real cop a real detective
dave toshi who would later become famous
as one of the lead investigators on the
zodiac case okay if you saw the david
fincher zodiac movie that was the
character played by mark ruffalo uh so
that's where he got the you know the uh
thing that he held his like [ __ ]
sidearm in yeah uh that
and uh so and just kind of his whole
because they knew each other the two of
them steve mcqueen and dave toshi they
had worked together previously and um so
he used him as inspiration on uh and i
think actually you know what's weird i
think even in the movie zodiac the dave
adventure one i think they even
mentioned that
like they mentioned that steve mcqueen's
character was based on him so i was like
ooh meta um also can we talk about oh
wait a minute i want to say
the director of this was uh peter yates
he was a british guy this was actually
his first american film uh he had done a
film called robbery in the uk which
steve mcqueen really dug
and so that's why steve mcqueen wanted
him to direct this film so he got him
over here to do it uh peter yates also
did breaking away he did the dresser the
deep uh which jacqueline bessette was
also in that eyewitness mother jugs and
speed remember that one um and crawl
unfortunately
can we also talk about
the score of this movie yeah i
love
the score of this movie it's just so
late 60s cool jazz
it's fantastic fantastic yeah it is
that's another thing that kind of made
me think of a blade runner
yeah the blade runner had a lot of jazz
and a lot of stuff
a lot of you know [ __ ] what's his
name who directed blade runner oh [ __ ]
ridley's got it ready scott ridley scott
was doing bullet bullet in the future
that's what i believe it was it is kind
of it's weird because the two movies are
you would think on the surface like
entirely different
but tonally they are kind of similar
yeah bullet was san francisco blade
runner was los angeles
yeah it was it was he was he was
borrowing from that
it was good good movie you know they're
both good movies
but i was going to say that he says hold
on somebody said did did steve mcqueen
ever make a bad movie
i don't know not that i ever saw because
i haven't seen all of them probably not
this is an era in um
in hollywood history where
steve mcqueen had a lot of money he if
he didn't like a movie he didn't have to
make it
yeah and this movie was actually like
his production company was kind of
behind it
and if you were going to put mcqueen in
a movie you had to have a lot of money
and if he didn't like the script he
wouldn't do it that's based on what i
remember and somebody mentioned that
mcqueen and um
and
um bruce lee were friends yeah yeah you
know there was a lot of cliques in
hollywood's and a lot of the cool guys
that were known for action type roles
they all went to the same parties
together they knew each other
and uh some got along some didn't
but uh evidently [ __ ] mcqueen when
mcqueen showed up he basically ran the
show everybody loved it
he was just
he just commanded a lot of respect
just by being who he was everybody you
know everybody in hollywood respected
him
you know because he wasn't a fake yeah
you know
a lot of guys were fakes but mcqueen
could
he was racing his cars and his
motorcycles you know in between movies
so you know
zack says something i love in movies
from this era is how filmmaking was
becoming more experimental but not to
the point of being pretentious and still
tells a story it isn't just abstract
[ __ ] yeah this is actually a really
great um honestly if i had to pick a
favorite
decade in film it would probably be the
70s
um but you know this is
all almost like an honorary 70s movie i
guess the 70s were almost almost
starting it was 70s was a couple months
yeah
there's my creepy phone ringing again uh
people are talking about the french
connection too which i actually do want
to get to yeah
i remember the title i've never seen
because that also has a great car chase
i've been hearing about bullet off and
on my whole and sorcerer that's another
one i gotta write that one down too
because i was just thinking about that
one today william freaking you know same
guy that did the exercise he also did
sorcerer and i want to do uh french
connections i had always heard of
mcqueen you know but it was this is like
more my dad's generation and i had never
seen this movie i haven't seen my this
is my only second steve mcqueen move
i've ever seen
yeah because i showed you the greatest
escape we saw that a couple weeks ago i
haven't seen well you've seen you've
seen the blob right the original yeah
that's true that's true which you know
where he plays a 35 year old teenager
yeah yeah
but you know that's part of its charm
uh so i guess i guess it's not the first
steve mcqueen movie i've seen yeah i
mean there's a bunch that i haven't seen
i have seen several of them but
i mean i'd seen bullet before but i
hadn't seen that since i was like for
[ __ ] 20 or 30. i've never seen this
movie it's a good movie yeah and same
and same with great escape i saw that
when i was maybe a teenager but i hadn't
seen it since then i just remember does
it hold up to today's movies
not really um is it is it a great movie
yeah it is it's a movie of its time oh
and ahead of its time really it's an
important movie a lot of stuff came from
this
and you're watching you're like damn
this is 68 this is some good [ __ ]
uh so it you could tell that this movie
is changing the game
oh it's a classic
uh it's like it it is something that you
should kind of watch you should watch
this one yeah it's kind of one of those
movies that i mean if you're interested
in film particularly like american film
uh you know there's a certain number of
movies that you kind of need to see
like to at least have some kind of
basis from like so you know you're
talking about yeah and uh i definitely
think this is in there just because it's
like so so influential on so many other
movies detective flick yeah but i wanted
to say when we were talking about the
score was that the guy who did the score
i saw his name uh uh lalo shiffrin in
the credits and i was like oh man that
dude's famous i know like and i couldn't
remember like any of the other movies he
did he also did
uh mission impossible yeah uh you know
very famous amityville horror okay thx
1138 all right all the dirty hairy
movies enter the dragon all right and
cool hand luke among many other things
so
that's the same guy that uh did the
music for this because i really really
like the music honestly i really like
the whole look of this
film like i said it's realistic but
i don't know that's kind of like a style
all of its own because it's not
because you know how sometimes like
they'll have a movie and they're like
trying to make it
gritty and realistic but it's almost
like affected because you can tell that
they're trying
this one doesn't seem like it's trying
it's just very very naturalistic and
organic yeah and it's almost like you're
not even thinking that it's a movie yeah
is that weird to say it kind of has that
sort of like vibe about it but not like
it's a documentary you know what i mean
it's hard to explain yeah but i yeah i
kind of feel like that's like a hard
style to like get across another thing
that uh blade runner ripped off from
this is that there's a scene in the
airport where uh bullet shoots a guy
who's in between
two glass doors
of the of the airport and the guy breaks
them while he's being shot
and it's just like that scene i think
her name is
zera or zera the the uh the replicant
stripper who's
getting shot in the back yeah running
through the glass door through the glass
window through the storefronts windows
and uh
it looks like that's where it looks like
that's where ridley scott got that idea
from this movie
there's just a lot of stuff in this
movie it looks like ripley's scott i
don't want to say ripped it off his
homaging
well like i said earlier that whole the
whole
end scene of bullet where he's chasing
the mobster like through the airport
yeah like across the tarmac uh michael
mann used that almost exact scene in
heat like it's pretty much
i don't see you know like i said it's
not shot for shot the same yeah but you
can totally tell that he's homaging that
yeah big time and where deckard comes in
and sees rachel's in bed and [ __ ]
he's like let's get out of here and then
he finds the little origami thing and
then they hit the door and just that's
the end that's not the original cut the
original
theatrical cut they're in a car and it's
all nice and sunny and they're driving
away that's that's
not the original cut that that's that
ridley scott wanted he wanted the blink
one where they just hit the door and it
ends
which one of my blade runner
uh blu-rays has that ending and that's
that's the ending of bullet now i'd be
kind of curious to see if anybody on
youtube or anybody on the internet
anywhere had done a side-by-side
comparison of bullet and blade runner
yeah there's a lot of stuff that he that
i think now i'm gonna i'm gonna go look
for that after because now i'm curious i
wanted to say too that this movie is
actually based on a novel that came out
in 1963 called mute witness now the
weird thing about that is that i'm
pretty sure that in the late 80s or
early 90s there was another there was a
movie called mute witness
and i'm pretty sure i saw it although i
can't remember that much about it but i
don't know if it was based on the same
novel or if it was just
uh just happen to be the same name
because that's not like a real original
title i guess
but i just thought when i saw that in
the credits i was like hey there was a
movie and i want to say it was 1991 or
something i think i used to have it on
dvd but i don't i think i only saw it
once and i remember it being good but i
don't remember what happened in it i
don't know if it's based on this same
thing though because i could have sworn
that in that movie
the whole mute witness thing it was like
a woman that had seen a crime and that
she was actually mute like she couldn't
talk
i think that was the premise but it's
been a long time since i've seen it so
i'm not really sure
[Laughter]
joanna cassidy was hot as [ __ ] blade
runner just saying she was the one that
was running through the glass right i
think so
um
so uh captain blair gave me an idea for
a show
uh the urantia the thing about uh
kellogg you know what i mean and his
weird like
spa thing
yeah yeah where you go to get get well
from cancer and die
and then
well anything really and like you
weren't allowed to like masturbate and
it was just kind of like this whole
thing it's like a it's like a weird cult
thing yeah
honestly a lot of hospitals were
yeah these uh
kind of like a private hospitals where
you could go to get better from just
things
anything they just claim they claim
anything things and stuff oh yeah
rheumatism whatever it is
we'll cure that
cancer we'll cure them your whateverism
were just like big wooden houses when
you looked at them
and people checked in and a lot of some
of them things they never checked out of
like a road they just died in there yeah
yeah and you paid you paid to die in
that [ __ ] they give you [ __ ]
like brass cereal
yeah that's kind of like where the whole
kellogg thing is and actually i haven't
thought of of that in terms of doing a
show about it but honestly that might
make an actually good give you some
brand cereal and some filtered water and
you'll be all right
stop jerking off
you know fix it
fix it yeah and you can do it in the
clean dry air up north somewhere in the
winter time you know that's that was the
[ __ ] the way they were you know the
1800s but there was
medicine
medicine is a scam and i think even to
this day a lot of it is scammed well i
kind of feel like back then they didn't
really they were kind of like groping
around in the dark they didn't have any
idea was like well this kind of works
sometimes maybe like on certain people
it's like well sometimes it works and
sometimes they didn't have any [ __ ]
people [ __ ] drinking radium yeah they
did it's a radioactive [ __ ] fluids
and [ __ ] your [ __ ] jaw fall off
[ __ ] kill you eat you up from the
inside [ __ ] radioactive fluids uh
they had people standing in front of
them x-ray machines it took a
live-action image of you moving that
[ __ ] would kill you there was a lot of
things that they did back then that
would [ __ ] kill you
um
then there was no they didn't regulate
anything yeah it took a while
and then even even once regulation
happened you could always just bribe
those regulators that
to a certain extent i think still a lot
of that shit's going on some of these
weird drugs that they'll try to sell you
[ __ ] through the television prize sec
and [ __ ] alopecia vision [ __ ] all
these weird ass [ __ ] names whatever
happened to those drugs
you know and did they actually work
um how effective were they what were the
[ __ ] side effects you know they only
sold the [ __ ] for a couple years and
then they replaced it with another one
because they constantly have to have a
new product well sometimes it's not that
sometimes uh because of the uh what not
what do you call them like a patent laws
what will happen is that if you develop
a drug you only have a patent for it on
x number of years or whatever it is
and then so you can sell it under your
brand name and then but after that then
anybody can make it and sell it so
sometimes it's the same drug but it just
has a different name because it's a
different company making it that's all
it is because the the patent uh expired
it was why there's that show a couple
days ago and says there's only two drugs
that's really changed humanity
are two things it's been around for
[ __ ] ever
and if you have these two
medicines
at hand it'll [ __ ] it'll solve about
80 of the [ __ ] that'll ever happen to
you the first one is penicillin okay if
you have penicillin [ __ ] that'll help
the other one i don't want to say it
because the algorithms will give me they
call it horse paste that right there
does a lot of [ __ ] for anti-parasitical
stuff
uh it's also antiviral just those two
right there have saved [ __ ]
tens or hundreds of millions of people
since since they've been around
and they don't have much sight of not no
real side effects i think to speak of
and it just takes care of a lot of [ __ ]
but the drug companies can't make any
money on them it costs pennies
but you'd stock up on those two things
right there especially penicillin
penicillin is [ __ ] people don't
realize what it was like before
antibiotics
damn
just a cut could kill you
one in a hundred says talking about
crime films have folks seen get carter
from 1971 i have uh i checked your
channel page and it wasn't on there i
think it's good i did write it down
though because we'll get around to it
eventually because like i said you know
we like to get to all these movies and
i've seen a lot more movies than we
reviewed on the show because i've seen a
lot like before i met him you know uh
danny rolling ghostface what's
tomorrow's movie jenny we decided this
is gonna be weird but i guess because we
were talking about steve mcqueen because
like i said we did bullet and like a few
weeks ago we did a great escape and then
we were talking about the blob and i
said you know what i think i want to
watch the 80s blob because i remember it
being really good
so we watched it last night and i was
like hot damn this movie was like even
better than i remember yeah i better not
remember the 80s from 1988 so we're
doing the blob from 1988 on tomorrow's
show we already we watched it last night
so i like the better gremlins
a lot darker than gremlins uh quality
about the same man the special effects
really do hold up too from like 1988
really really gruesome i was into it
gremlins was what 86 84 84 yeah yeah
okay the effects i think were the
effects in the budget i'd probably put
it at what gremlins was
but a lot darker
uh it had some humor in it yeah
man it was good
the movie held up
i didn't realize that um i don't want to
like because the effects are really good
yeah they really are well i didn't
realize that frank darabont was a was a
co-writer on it so there was that too
but yeah so we're going to talk about
the 80s blob
tomorrow because i've been wanting to
rewatch that we finally did last night
it was on amazon prime but you get to
pay 3.99 but it's worth it it's good all
right so drove down down said radium is
a show right there i know it did yeah i
wrote that down because i'm always
looking for like interesting show topics
you know here drink this it's
radioactive you'll be fine and radiation
it helps you
yeah i guess they thought it was hurting
like a superhero
well they didn't know i guess they
thought it would be like chemo
yeah because i mean if you say it like
that then i mean you know chemotherapy
sounds [ __ ] up too it's like hey let's
give somebody something that'll kill all
your cells yeah but sometimes there's a
famous picture of a dude that he doesn't
have a bottom jaw just it's black and
white it's just a [ __ ] teeth man with
his [ __ ]
oh it's nasty you can find that
photograph that was radium
[ __ ] it ate that dude's bottom jaw
off
yep oh and i'm sure that was uh not fun
cancer
cancer ate his [ __ ] bottom johnny
just his tongue hanging oh it was like a
medical photo he was standing there and
he lived like that for quite a while
horrible
radium did that i just can't imagine did
he have to like
well would he have to keep his tongue
damp all the time he didn't like put
sponges on it oh he couldn't have been
in public back in those areas he must
have lived at a hospital well yeah you'd
have to wear a bag over your head like
an elephant [ __ ] scream if they saw
you it just looked like he looked like a
walking people were a little sensitive
back then he's still sensitive today
if you saw that you go
well no you wouldn't because well i mean
maybe expect it a little kid would if
you didn't expect that [ __ ] man you see
that just but i think most people would
have the presence of mind to like not
they might be like startled but they're
not gonna like scream their head off or
anything i don't think [ __ ] looked
horrible
you know unless you thought it was like
unless you legit thought that it was a
zombie
invasion or something that poor guy and
uh evidently they just sold radium over
the counters and he was just a [ __ ]
he was a fan of it he just you know
drinking like it was an energy drink or
something
danny rolling ghostface says tom should
wear a mullet wig like kevin dillon
sports and the blob remake yeah you
don't have one honestly
honestly the hair that kevin dillon has
in the zob remake was kind of like your
hair when you were a teenager yeah um
his hair was bigger and a little
fluffier yeah a little bigger and
curlier i wasn't more conservative but
yours was yours was more like a rick
springfield yeah whereas his was kind of
more actually if you look if you look um
if you go back and look all right around
that same time that was the similar hair
to what [ __ ] andrew eldridge had
it was
yeah i mean looking at it now i was like
wow man that hair is out of control but
in 1988 a lot of people had that hair
and no one would about it yeah you had
gots to have that hair even though it
looks kind of ridiculous nowadays but
you just put gel in it and make it
[ __ ]
spiky and you could get you had goths
that had that yeah you could get andrew
eldridge or kind of like smooth it down
on the sides yeah so because kevin
dylan's was very like floofy yeah i
thought
but yeah we'll talk about that tomorrow
because we're gonna talk about the blog
i'm kind of excited about it because
like i said i hadn't seen it in a long
time i just remember being really
kick-ass and uh i was like we need to
watch that again so we ran it and i was
like man that was like even better than
i remembered it was that was it was
super fun one of the only [ __ ] dudes
who didn't have that [ __ ] mullet
who's being high speed on us being
futuristic was [ __ ] uh the deuce from
bauhaus
andrew
what's his name peter murphy didn't have
that no
um
he had short spiky hair yeah it was a
high tech you're like man that's some
[ __ ] badass air but then if you look
who actually had a mullet but it was
just turned into a mohawk was [ __ ]
the guitar player daniel and daniel ash
that was kind of a mullet exaggerated
mullet peter murphy had a little bit of
a mullet but sometimes sometimes but
then like later like right around 82 he
just cut it real short so it was like
short in the back and like slightly
longer and kind of spiky in the front
yeah we didn't there was no word mullet
yeah that wasn't until later
that was just a standard and it wasn't
associated with rednecks until
probably the late 80s i want to say
maybe later they were trying to cool up
their system yeah they were adopting our
haircuts and then they cut their [ __ ]
sleeves off their [ __ ] denim [ __ ]
shirts but damn shirts one of their
[ __ ] plaid shirts
yeah then put a [ __ ] hat on
danny rowling says uh rat tails were the
worst hairstyle ever created in my
opinion i mean there's probably a lot of
competition in that area but i saw that
was that girl from [ __ ] till tuesday
i liked her hair though yeah she but it
was she it was great her electro hair
was white yeah that little [ __ ]
braided rat tail come down
it's cute
i mean well you couldn't really see it
yeah you couldn't really see it from the
front uh from the front it's just like i
still like her hair yeah you know what i
mean amy man her name handyman yeah she
was cute and that was kind of a goth
haircut for the day
yeah it was it was very cool looking
yeah it's all platinum
uh fourth throwdown said bono had an
impressive mullet yeah but he had a
really big mullet too like i said a lot
of people had it and it wasn't
associated it was more of a new wave
thing in the early 80s it was like a
really cool like ahead of the curve kind
of hairstyle it was just later it got
appropriated
and then you couldn't really have it
anymore yeah grandpa says we're up in
michigan [ __ ] we're running around
[ __ ] being bono and mel gibson and
leave the weapon
yeah
we didn't really know it we didn't know
what it was because everybody kind of
had that haircut it was just a haircut
this is a cool haircut yeah yeah peter
murphy i remember doing those adverts
for
uh something i don't know what that is i
can't remember exactly him just sitting
there it was um
was it magnavox i thought he did one
from memorex memorex that's what it was
yeah where he was that he was sitting in
that chair and then like the speaker was
like whoa
yes
yeah but that well it's weird because
they had another version of that
commercial that had another actor in it
yeah i don't think we got the peter
murphy version in the u.s but we got
another version that had another guy in
it but i have seen the british one yeah
that was actually peter murphy i don't
know if he was in any other commercials
other than that but i think that's the
one that he was most famous for yeah i'm
pretty sure it was memorex
like yeah is it real or is it memorex
why did i think magnavox i guess because
it starts
it starts and ends with the same letter
i guess i don't know
oh my god all right so uh are are we
done yeah we're gonna shut it down okay
man we went on for an hour again holy
crap
maxell cassettes that's it yeah that's
what it was that's what it is okay so em
there was a lot of m's and x's
in all of the things that we said so you
know
yeah it was maxwell that's right that's
what it was i think i had i think i
still ha i don't think i was black on my
photo of him sitting there wouldn't it
black and white with the [ __ ]
speakers there and he's in that big old
[ __ ] chair yeah yeah blasting him
blasting his hair back or something yeah
i think i had that yeah because it was a
print ad too it wasn't just a tv ad it
was also like like a print ad because i
think i have magazines yeah
all right uh oh and rob mentions the car
chase from the seven ups which yes i
heard somebody else talking about that
somebody's talking about french
connection and was somebody who was
talking about the 7-ups as well so we'll
eventually get around to that one too
there's like a lot of movies we still
need to get around to so we'll you know
just be patient we'll get around all of
them eventually
we got all the time in the world maybe
don't don't say that it's a little like
curse us one of us to get hit by a bus
or something but you know
all right so we'll be back tomorrow
talking about uh the blob from 1988
uh so thanks everybody for dropping by
and we will see you guys again tomorrow